good morning believe nation it's Evan my
one word is believe and I believe that
you have something special that when you
unleash it it will be able to change the
world so to help you on your journey
today's message is don't get stuck in
unhappiness over to you Eckhart Tolle so
called unhappiness is also a childish
way of trying to change things by being
as unhappy as you can about them and the
underlying unconscious or semi-conscious
assumption is if I'm really unhappy
somebody perhaps God is going to do
something about it or I'm going to prove
him wrong I'm going to show him how
dreadful it is and then finally this is
an unconscious assumption behind the
unhappiness because you believe if
you're habitually and frequently unhappy
you believe that it has a purpose it's
an underlying assumption perhaps you
wouldn't verbalize it in that way but
you believe that it it's it works for
you because it doesn't but things are
going to change but just need to be
really unhappy so that God finally even
if you don't believe in God this this
can still be the mechanism the
underlying unconscious assumption behind
it it's something's going to happen and
of course the opposite is true because
the more happier with something the more
you're stuck in the situation I think
the fastest way to get unstuck is to
change your environment whatever it is
that you're unhappy with whatever it is
that you desperately want to change the
fastest way to do it is to change your
environment because if you will have to
consciously think about it you can think
your way out of it in the short term if
you are unhappy if you're sad you can
consciously think okay I want to be
happier what can I do to make myself
happier and you come up with a plan for
the day and maybe you read a book or you
watch a video and that changes your your
tone or
you put on a music video and you're
dancing or celebrating and whatever it
is and that sets you up for the rest of
the day but then you start over the next
day and you're back to where you were
and it's difficult to change because it
requires so much conscious thinking it
requires too much planning you're not
going to wake up every day and plan
something it just takes up too much
effort energy and work and so what I
find that really helps is by changing
the environment so you plan once when
you're in the zone you're feeling like
you want to make that change and then
you change your environment to support
the new habit or belief system that you
want so you know if you want to learn
Japanese the fastest way to learn
Japanese is go to Japan all right you'll
learn way more than going to a class
once a week right and so whatever it is
that you want if you want happiness if
you want joy if you want love if you
want whatever your one word is for me is
believe I won't believe daily I want to
wake up and have believe take care of
itself I don't want to wake up every day
and think okay how do I make today more
believe it's just too much effort every
day especially when you first wake up
and you're you might be groggy or tired
I had a rough night and you don't want
to make important decisions you want to
fall out of your day and too often we
just we do that we fall out of bed and
fall into our day and it's not done with
any kind of design where if your
environment forces that on you it's much
easier and so there's a reason why in my
office there's those posters on the wall
all right this is a reason why I have a
morning routine that sets me up for
success is a reason why I make these
videos and I watch the videos and I'm
doing the research like it all helps me
add more belief to my life and it's
scheduled in it's part of the
environment is part of my daily routine
when that happens and it pulls me to a
new place so I don't need to think daily
about how to get inspired how to feel
more believe it just happens because I
planned that in it just happens
naturally every single day and so I'd
encourage you to do the same thing if
you know what you want if you know what
your one where it is what you stand for
or you just know I don't want to be
unhappy anymore and I want more joy in
my life
great what brings you joy what does joy
look like
what does a joyful morning routine look
like if joy is hugging your dog in the
morning
great then can we hug your dog every
morning right make a joy music playlist
that you put on as soon as you wake up
if joy is doing you know gratitude
session while meditating outside and the
Sun let go do that whatever the thing is
what's on the wall when you wake up what
do you look at does it make you feel
joyful it might be as simple as having a
Minnie Mouse plate that you eat your
breakfast on and looking at that reminds
you of the great time you had in Disney
World growing up and that makes you feel
joyful like things like that everything
in your environment how do I make my
kitchen set more joyful and my knives
more joyful and my table talk more
joyful in my environment what's on the
wall like all of that relate and it may
sound stupid but if it's in your
environment and it just happens on its
own without you having to do anything
yes you set it up once but you don't do
it daily it just happens to you on a
daily basis you're much more likely to
feel the feeling that you want as
opposed to waking up and trying to plan
and trying to think your way through
whatever pain and suffering you're
having right now I find that it's it's a
tremendously beneficial for me and I
hope that if you take that mindset
forward and try to plan a perfect
morning routine in playing in an
environment around you that you'll be
able to get unstuck from whatever is
sticking to you right now and more than
just getting unstuck because then you're
just in a neutral state right like okay
I lost that frustration but now I'm just
neutral I want you to be great I want
you to do amazing things every single
day and it's hard to do that when you
have a really poor environment around
you so change it so the question today
is I'm curious what is one thing that
you changed about your environment that
made a big impact on your feeling on
your life on your business whether it
was a picture on the wall or changing
your knife set or whatever it was
something in your environment that you
changed I love to hear your thoughts
please share in the comments below I
think it could be really beneficial for
other members of believe nation to to
see what worked for you to give them
some ideas and inspiration to change
things in their lives
I also want to give a quick shout out to
Judy Globo card Judy thank you so much
for picking up a copy of my book your
one word it really really really means a
lot to me and I hope you're enjoying the
read so thank you guys again for
watching I believe in you I hope we
continue to believe in yourself and
whatever your one word is much love and
I'll see you guys again tomorrow morning
for another shot of espresso
[Music]
she's worried about the rent okay she's
a single mother sure a better carriage
you know and then you could do about the
rent worrying about it I don't gonna get
you to rent presents and Happiness gets
you rent money can't make you happy but
happy can make you money so be happy go
out in the world with your story the guy
in TLC rolls over in the morning
meditates goes out into the world it's
like damn I'm gonna have to get some
bread and water before the whole go down
before I get back in that bed but the
meantime be nice to all my neighbors in
the village everybody is suffering and
what everyone else calls extreme poverty
but he's happy he didn't have a poverty
mindset no is he worried about that
bread and water they don't give me some
bread I don't worry about that now I'm
that dude he walks out smiling confident
comfortable he gets what he needs he
says but Yogananda would say God will
provide but really your God just working
to get and it will shows up he gets his
bread and water he makes everybody happy
everybody makes him happy ladies in the
bed next [ __ ] he wakes up he's got a
you know you know 36 billion dollars in
the bank he gets up the stock box goes
up he says oh get some coke get some
alcohol gets happy so excited I'm
exploding you're making more money more
money morning Oh crash more cocaine more
alcohol of his hot gold up and down and
he dies at 40 this house guy lives at a
hundred if he had the other guy's diet
not to diet el the guy took but the
other guy's opportunity for have a
greater diet the guy in the house met
would have made a hut in 20 but you know
made a hundred this guy died at 40
that's the reality of all you know our
happiness is up to us you know our
relationship with the world is up to us
our anxiety is controlled or given to us
by us if you follow your passion you're
going to be successful no matter what
because one you'll be happy and I think
happiness is really important you can't
do anything well if you're not happy you
can't be a good parent good spouse
girlfriend boyfriend you can't be a good
co-worker happiness is important and
that doesn't mean you forea every day
but a basic sense of peace
and for some of us especially Taipei and
especially people were hard on ourselves
we don't give each other give ourselves
a break and so the pursuit of happiness
as we have it written obviously in our
Declaration of Independence is something
that is challenging so pursuing
happiness that they do think is
important as a pursuit of anything else
what's success anyway its success about
making the most money no not no money
for the most part turns people into
jerks if you if you do become rich the
university fundraising and development
office will certainly want to stay in
touch with you and if you give enough
money you'll get your name on a plaque
above the dirty laundry bin here in the
men's locker room but that still doesn't
make you a great person and it
definitely doesn't mean anyone will like
you I mean don't get me wrong as I
mentioned before you're never gonna feel
richer than when you've paid off those
credit cards and student loans but after
that money tends to be pretty
unfulfilled
almost all the people I know have made a
lot of money they turned into that guy
all right well you know the guy who pops
his collar and if he and if it were up
to him and you're wearing two shirts he
could pop both collars that's the guy so
how will we know when we've done it
right what's the ultimate measure of
success then what's the key to success
well in my experience quite simply
success is happiness it all comes down
to happiness and I definitely don't mean
that happiness that you feel when the
Gophers take over on downs in their own
red zone as great as that feels I mean
that happiness that quite literally
fills your lungs the kind of happiness
that makes a noise it announces its
arrival with a deep inhale on a deep
exhale that happiness you know that
happiness right that happiness is
success because it turns out happy
people get jobs happy people create
happy people win happy people fall in
love and raise families they lead and
change the world
happy people get what they want because
often happy people are the ones who
realize they don't actually need much
more than they already have and they
appreciate what they've got
happy people are contagious and every
one of us here has the chance to be
truly happy